salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
dès qu'on parle de voitures on est tous
convaincus d'être d'excellents
conducteurs ou conductrices on a
tendance à surestimer nos capacités et à
l'inverse à sous-estimer les imprévus et
les dangers qui peuvent survenir sur la
route j'ai rendez-vous dans un centre
d'essai pour un petit stage de conduite
allez en piste tout le monde va en
profiter
bien Thibault on commence par quoi du
freinage d'urgence à quelle vitesse va
rouler le véhicule à 30 km/h c'est très
peu tranquille c'est très peu mais on va
s'apercevoir que c'est vraiment beaucoup
dès qu'on va être dans une zone où on
croise beaucoup d'autres formes de
mobilité et notamment toutes les
personnes qui sont pas protégées pour
une carrosserie et pour nous aider on va
simuler grâce à ces quatre cônes bleues
l'endroit où on veut déclencher notre
freinage d'urgence c'est-à-dire qu'au
moment où le nez de la voiture va
arriver au niveau de ses plots
j'écrase le frein vulgairement tu pile
tu peux y aller voilà on y est tu es
prêt on écrase les points j'ai fait ce
que tu m'as dit allons mesurer bon
distance de freinage assez courte tu
t'attendais à quoi je sais pas trop en
fait mais ça me donne déjà un ordre
d'idée je suis à 2,5 ans
on va mettre notre paire ce cône blanc à
l'endroit où on s'est arrêté à 30 km/h
d'accord si on met un repère ça veut
dire qu'on n'a pas fini l'exercice
continuons soyons joueurs si on doublait
la vitesse 60 km/h j'imagine qu'un
cultivement la plupart des personnes se
disent on va deux fois plus vite on va
aller deux fois plus loin par expérience
effectivement c'est la pensée de
pratiquement de monsieur tout le monde
voilà
tu es prêt on y est bientôt regarde loin
regarde loin
[Musique]
psychologiquement je suis très très loin
de l'endroit où j'avais mis les plots je
rappelle qu'initialement lorsque je
roulais à 30 km/h il m'a fallu 2 mètres
50 pour m'arrêter qu'en roulant à 60
km/h
intuitivement on se dit il faut deux
fois plus de distance donc 5 mètres dans
la réalité voilà où on s'est arrêté
12 mètres 12 mètres plus de 4 fois plus
on va reprendre les données du problème
pour s'arrêter une voiture doit évacuer
toute l'énergie cinétique qu'elle a
emmagasiné c'est à dire l'énergie qui
est liée à son mouvement cette énergie
cinétique est égale à la moitié de la
masse du véhicule multipliée par la
vitesse au carré à 30 km/h on multiplie
donc 30 par 30 par 900 dans ces
conditions la distance de freinage
nécessaire pour évacuer l'énergie
cinétique en magasinée par le véhicule
que je conduisais est d'environ
3 mètres
à 60 km/h maintenant cette énergie est
égale à la moitié de la masse de mon
véhicule toujours multipliée par 60 au
carré autrement dit multiplié par 3600
c'est 4 fois plus voilà pourquoi il m'a
fallu à 60 km/h 12 mètres pour m'arrêter
par conséquent quand la vitesse est
multipliée par deux la distance de
freinage est multipliée par 4 d'où
l'importance de respecter la limitation
de vitesse même un petit excès
peut-ongendrer de graves conséquences
et c'est parti même chose que tout à
l'heure même chose essayez d'accélérer
vraiment assez tôt pour vraiment arriver
à une vitesse stabilisée comme ça on se
concentre un signal sur le top continue
top
ok allons mesurer
ah oui on s'est arrêté bien avant bien
avant mesurons on revient à 50 je suis à
8 4 mètres 4 m de différence cette
distance te paraît pas familière en
ville c'est la largeur d'un passage
piéton ce qui veut dire là où je me
trouve à l'entrée du passage piéton avec
ta voiture à 60 km/h tu roules encore à
au moins 30 km/h on voit donc que 10
km/h d'excès en ville 60 au lieu de 50
c'est extrêmement dangereux pour les
piétons en effet cela nécessite la
largeur d'un passage piéton en plus pour
que le véhicule s'arrête d'ailleurs pour
être parfaitement juste la distance de
freinage n'est pas le seul paramètre à
prendre en compte pour l'arrêt du
véhicule il faut ajouter la distance
liée temps de réaction voilà un appareil
qui permet de mesurer le temps de
réaction alors comment vais-je pouvoir
connaître mon temps de réaction on a
reproduit une situation de conduite
grâce à un capteur qui est au sol qui
représente ta de frein on va
commencer par le mode le plus facile
donc le temps de réaction simple tu vas
freiner quand le voyant rouge s'allume
tu vas mettre le pied dans un premier
temps à droite de la pour simuler
que tu as ton pied sur l'accélérateur
c'est parti
va pouvoir relâcher et là on s'aperçoit
tu as zéro 47 secondes de temps de
réaction une demi seconde presque une de
mes secondes alors c'est pas beaucoup
mais pendant ce temps là la voiture se
déplace et là quelle distance a-t-elle
parcourue à 50 km/h pendant ces 0,47
secondes tu as parcouru 7 mètres tu as
dit que c'était le cas le plus simple un
cas un peu plus compliqué cette fois je
vais pas te demander simplement
d'appuyer sur le frein à l'allumage
d'une lumière rouge mais à l'allumage
d'un symbole inconnu qu'est-ce que ça
change le fait que ce soit un symbole
inconnu l'analyse qu'on va demander à
ton cerveau ça va s'approcher d'une
situation plus réelle de conduite tu vas
devoir freiner à ce symbole on peut
lancer et moi j'ai mis
tu saurais m'appeler épicurieux à
l'envers et puis curieux à l'envers
c'est X
ah malin alors là mon temps était
beaucoup plus élevé j'ai fait plus d'une
seconde j'étais concentré sur le signal
mais en plus tu me parlais je
réfléchissais en même temps il m'a fallu
plus de temps pour réagir tout
simplement pour réagir tout à l'heure
mon temps de réaction était de 0,47
secondes me semble-t-il et la distance
parcourue pendant ce laps de temps était
de 7 mètres là qu'est-ce que ça donne
pour une seconde 0 une 14 mètres deux
fois plus deux fois plus quand un
obstacle surgit sur la route ou qu'un
événement imprévu se produit on ne peut
pas réagir instantanément on l'a vu
c'est impossible hein les images captées
par les yeux sont d'abord transmises au
cerveau de celui-ci analyse les données
étroit si la situation est jugée trop
dangereuse et bien le cerveau commande
au pied d'appuyer sur la de frein
seulement le temps que ce processus
aboutisse il s'écoule entre une demi
seconde si l'on est attentif à
si on les moins tant pendant lequel le
véhicule continue à avancer pour
déterminer la distance nécessaire à un
véhicule pour s'arrêter il faut donc
ajouter à la distance de freinage la
distance parcourue pendant le temps de
réaction à 30 km/h ce véhicule parcourt
9 mètres en une seconde pour s'arrêter
il aura donc besoin de 9 mètres distance
parcourue pendant le temps de réaction
une seconde auquel il faut ajouter 3
mètres
distance de freinage soit un total de 12
mètres à 60 km/h le véhicule parcourt
maintenant 18 mètres en une seconde pour
s'immobiliser il aura donc besoin de 18
mètres distance parcourue pendant le
temps de réaction auquel on ajoute 12
mètres distance de freinage soit un
total de 30 mètres pour s'immobiliser
quels conseils peut-on donner aux
automobilistes pour réduire cette
distance liée au temps de réaction
bien sûr baisser la vitesse mais est-ce
qu'il y a autre chose tu vas pouvoir
appliquer une seule technique ce qu'on
appelle le pied au frein dès que tu vas
pressentir une situation à risque tu vas
pas laisser ton pied droit sur
l'accélérateur mais tu vas déjà le
préparer juste devant la ce petit
geste anodin va avoir un effet très
important on va le refaire en mode
facile pour comparer avec la première
donnée je suis prêt à l'image de la
lumière rouge très bien pour rappel à 0
47 c'est ça
c'est parti
0,2808 ah oui j'ai gagné quand même 20
centièmes de seconde ça paraît rien dans
la vie 20 centièmes voyons voir ce que
ça nous apporte en mettre je suis passé
de 7 m à 4 m 3 m ça peut sauver une vie
ça peut sauver une vie c'est
pratiquement un passage piéton le temps
de réaction ne dépend pas que de notre
vitesse il dépend aussi de notre
attention et des distractions qu'on peut
avoir au volant dans notre monde hyper
connecté difficile de s'en passer près
de 80% des conducteurs français a voulu
l'utiliser au volant pire 34% à vous
lire ou écrire des SMS 24% consultez
leur notification
8%, publier des stories sur les réseaux
sociaux tout cela peut avoir de graves
conséquences ok Jamie je te propose une
nouvelle situation je vais te demander
d'envoyer un sms en conduisant
c'est internet ça c'est interdit mais
c'est pour ça qu'on le fait au cœur d'un
centre d'essai sur une route fermée à la
circulation OK et qu'est-ce que j'envoie
comme message et ben on va envoyer
l'adresse à Manu de la fête de ce soir
c'est 24 rue de la Glacière
24 rue de la Glacière
Paris 13 voilà surtout là j'aimerais
bien qu'il y ait personne en face ouais
c'est parti
heureusement qu'il y avait personne en
face parce que je pense qu'on
serait pas bien à cette heure-ci ah bon
parce que moi j'ai vraiment eu
l'impression de rester dans dans l'axe
tu as quand même pas mal quitté les yeux
de la route d'après une étude américaine
écrire un SMS au volant multiplie par 23
le risque d'accident il faut dire que
rien que la lecture d'un message
monopolyse l'attention pendant plusieurs
secondes
combien de temps avez-vous mis pour lire
ce sms 3 4 5 secondes et bien pendant ce
temps nos yeux ne regardent pas la route
alors que le véhicule lui continue la
sienne à 30 km/h en 3 secondes il
parcourt 27 mètres alors qu'il n'en fait
que 9 en une seconde ce qui augmente
considérablement la distance d'arrêt en
cas de nécessité et je ne vous parle pas
des écarts de trajectoire comme on l'a
vu dans l'expérience petit rappel
utiliser son téléphone au volant est
strictement interdit par la loi c'est
135 euros d'amende et trois points en
moins sur le permis la vitesse le
téléphone il y a un autre facteur
aggravant au volant l'alcool je te
propose un nouvel exercice cette fois
sur le thème de l'alcool au volant je
t'ai prévu en parcours avec des cônes
premier passage tu le feras à jeun tu
n'as pas bu tu seras donc le SAM et la
deuxième fois on va simuler ton
alcoolémie par des lunettes altérant ta
vision
et en faisant le SAM déjà tu vas
commencer par fermer la maison très bien
je te chronomètre
[Musique]
une minute 56 et voilà bon alors pas
trop mal une minute 506 c'est ton temps
de référence très bien aucun cône c'est
le plus important surtout voir sur la
deuxième partie maintenant la seule
différence c'est que les lunettes vont
perturber visuellement te recréer ce
défaut justement visuel d'équilibre que
va nous causer l'alcool et pour bien
mesurer tes gestes on va commencer de la
même façon je vais te lancer les clés
ah bah oui je les loupe ça et j'ai du
mal à les attraper je fais même
t'accompagner pour pas que tu tombes ouh
là oui j'ai l'impression tituber un
petit peu et maintenant je rejoins la
voiture ou j'ai l'impression que le sol
s'échappe sous mes pieds par sécurité
cette fois je vais peut-être monter avec
toi
je m'installe
je vais pouvoir lancer le chronomètre
c'est à droite pour rappel
mais je sais pas où je suis là j'ai
beaucoup de mal beaucoup beaucoup de mal
à repérer
ah oui oh là là là alors on imagine dans
une petite rue comme ça
l'état de la voiture qui ressort toute
griffée je sais pas où je suis là bon
j'avance bleue je vois les cônes bleues
ma fixe-toi ça comme objectif voilà
alors c'est dingue parce que
je vois double aussi
joyeuse ce qui est caractéristique ça ça
peut vraiment arriver et là on mesure le
danger quand on prend le volant dans cet
état et on le mesure bien parce que là
on est conscient parce que lorsqu'on a
bu il y a un truc en plus c'est que on
est désinhibé donc on mesure pas ce
danger et ça j'ai pas de moyens de te le
faire subir ou est-ce que je vais là ce
qui est dingue c'est que j'y vais un
petit peu au pif là
où est-ce que je suis pour ton
information tu as déjà dépassé ton temps
de plus d'une minute même pas me donner
un tout petit coup de main tu as bu tout
seul
tu étais pas tout seul il y en a
d'autres qui lui avec moi
je m'arrête là c'est c'est trop dur
pratiquement deux minutes de plus mais
dans quel état j'ai trouvé la voiture
bon tu es confiant écoute tant que j'ai
les lunettes ça va et je redoute le
moment où je vais les retirer bon après
avoir compter les verres on va compter
les dégâts
je crois que tu as fait le pare-choc tu
peux appeler l'assurance d'où
l'importance de surtout ne pas boire
quand on prend le volant effectivement
il y a une tolérance en France qui est
battu la connais bien de 0,5 g d'alcool
par litre de 200 voir 0,2 gramme parler
de 200 pour les conducteurs novice et
puis surtout si on va une soirée où on
sait qu'elle va être arrosée et bien on
donne les clés à celui qu'on doit
choisir le sam lui le SAM ne consomme
aucune goutte d'alcool on va revenir sur
certaines idées reçues concernant
l'alcool ça ne dépend pas de la boisson
que ce soit un demi un verre de vin ou
un alcool fort ces trois boissons
contiennent la même quantité d'alcool
pur
simplement la concentration qui change
que vous ayez consommé l’une ou l'autre
de ces trois boissons vous aurez absorbé
la même quantité d'alcool autre idée
reçue on entend souvent dire qu'en
mangeant on atténue les effets de
l'alcool c'est faux manger des cales
simplement le phénomène le taux
d'alcoolémie maximale est atteint 30
minutes après l'absorption si vous êtes
à jeun une heure si vous avez bu au
cours d'un repas ce qui tend le coup à
une autre idée reçue selon laquelle on
pourrait reprendre le volant si on s'est
arrêté de boire une heure avant il faut
simplement se souvenir que l'organisme
élimine au maximum
0,15 g d'alcool par heure et par litre
de sang il faut parfois une bonne nuit
de sommeil pour éliminer les excès allez
une dernière pour la route le café le
cachet d'aspirine pratiquer un exercice
physique intense ne fera pas descendre
votre taux d'alcoolémie le plus simple
on le répète celui qui conduit c'est
celui qui ne boit pas les voitures ne
sont pas seules sur la route de de moins
en moins surtout en ville où les vélos
sont de plus en plus nombreux du coup
les conducteurs de voitures doivent
rester extrêmement vigilants ils doivent
penser à mettre leurs clignotants en
amont pour indiquer qu'il change de
direction regardez dans les rétroviseurs
et vérifier les angles morts vérifier
qu'il n'y a personne au moment où il
tourne petit rappel lorsque une voiture
tourne à droite le vélo qui arrive sur
le côté est prioritaire
un type d'accident est de plus en plus
fréquent c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'emportière un conducteur s'arrête sur
le bas-côté et ouvre sa portière pour
sortir du véhicule et là Bing un
cycliste qui arrive sur le côté Hercule
la portière de plein fouet pour éviter
ce genre d'accident qui peut être très
grave il existe un geste l'ouverture de
la portière à la Hollandaise on
l'appelle ainsi parce que ce geste fait
partie du code de la route au Pays-Bas
il consiste à ouvrir la portière quand
on est conducteur avec la main droite de
cette manière le conducteur est obligé
de se retourner d'en trouver la portière
et là il vérifie qu'il n'y a personne
évidemment s'il y a un cycliste on le
laisse passer
côté vélo les cyclistes doivent
également songer à s'équiper à commencer
par un gilet réfléchissant tenez on va
faire une petite expérience il fait nuit
je suis sur une petite route de campagne
qui n'est pas éclairée j'ai mis mes feux
de croisement devant moi je ne vois rien
et pourtant il y a bien un cycliste
n'est-ce pas approche seulement sans
gilet réfléchissant et sans éclairage et
bien on ne le voit pas et ben
l'orgaspard on fait du vélo sans gérer
réfléchissant et sans mettre la lumière
allez on file ça
on brancher l'éclairage et maintenant tu
peux y aller et là et bien on voit le
cycliste de très très loin jusqu'à
180 mètres ce qui permet au conducteur
du véhicule d'anticiper les feux de
croisement d'une voiture n'est clair que
jusqu'à une distance de 30 mètres
autrement dit un cycliste qui ne porte
pas de gilet réfléchissant n'est visible
par le conducteur qui a cette distance
or à 90 km/h le véhicule la parcourt en
une seconde une seconde pour réagir et
éviter le cycliste c'est peu avec un
gilet réfléchissant comme ici et un bon
éclairage le cycliste est visible a au
moins 160 mètres ce qui laisse le temps
au conducteur pour anticiper et dépasser
le vélo en toute sécurité vous l'avez
compris il est essentiel pour un
cycliste d'être vu en plus du gilet
réfléchissant qui est obligatoire la
nuit en agglomération les vélos doivent
être équipés d'un éclairage à l'avant et
à l'arrière et de réflecteur après la
vue l'oreille
la sonnette est-elle aussi obligatoire
tout comme le casque pour les moins de
12 ans mais comme notre crâne est plutôt
fragile et bien il est également
recommandé pour les adultes les freins
doivent être en bon état et les
cyclistes doivent respecter le code de
la route ah oui dernière chose pas de
téléphone ni d'oreillette comment
voiture il perturbe l'attention la suite
et bien
il faut simplement rester en selle allez
je vous dis à très bientôt pour une
nouvelle vidéo
[Musique]